今日は 3回目の心の講義の 3回目なんです
で 心の育て方というテーマでございまして
で それに入る前にちょっと 5分ぐらい
この今までの講義のちょっと大事なポイントだけ
また思い出させていただきます
で 心ということをまず
心心と大雑把に言うんですけど
あの 何が心ですかと で
そこで世の中でいろいろ説明あるかもしれませんだけど
私たちは釈迦さんの教えではこういうものを心ですよと見てくださいで
特別な定義というか解釈というか
そういうものを申し上げたんです
どういうことかというと
この体は物体として見てくださいと
ただの物体 ただの物体として見たら
物体でない働きはいっぱいあるんですね
よく言うと 体は物体として
何か椅子とか机とか建物とか
そういうような物体と同じだと見ちゃったら
本当にものすごいたくさん働きがあるんですね
その物体と違った働きは
そういうものをすべての働きに我々は心と言うんだと
ですから 物体は生命体として区別する場合は
この区別できる可能にする一切の働きが心の働きであって
心という一つのものではないんですね
何かコンピューターみたいに
コンピューターの中に入っている CPU みたいに
何か体の中にある一箇所に心という大事な魂のようなものあるということではなくて
この体全体に命として生きているものとして働いている働きが心であります
ですから 私は手を伸ばす
それは機械的な働きだけではないんです
そこに心が働いているんですね
それでもう一つ ちょっと思い出してほしいことは
物体と機械なんですね
じゃあ物体と機械はどう違いますかというと
機械は人間考えて なんとか組み立てていて
ある決まっている動きをしてほしいと
ですから 機械はその決まっている動きだけしてくれる
でも生命体の場合はそうでもないんですね
生命体が自分の意思で動いているんですね
その動きも決まってはいるんだけど
例えば人は歩くとか 二本の足でしか歩けないし
飛べないし 動きは決まってはいるんだけど
そこに自分の意思で動いているんですね
そこら辺 機械と生命体の差なんですね
生命体は自分で行動する
機械はもう自分で行動するということじゃなくて
ただ決まっているパターンで行動する
ですから 例えばロボットがありまして
ロボットは人間と全く同じ形をしているかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり決まっている行動しかできない
で 人間の場合は またちょっと違っている行動できるんですね
それで物体と機械と それから生命体と 3つに分かれてみると
その生命体にある違うところはすべて心という働きであります
ですから 見ることも心であって
聞くことも心であって
味 香りを嗅ぐことも心であって
味わうことも心であって
体で感じることも心であって
それについていろんな行動をすることも心であって
それから機械には燃料を入れたりする
燃料は消化する 我々は食べ物は入れたりする
それは消化する それも人間にとっては燃料なんですけど
やっぱりその場合も機械とちょっと違う働きがあるんですね
食べ物を消化するときでも好き好き嫌いあったりして
自分で食べ物を工夫したりして
機械はそんなもの何もしません
そこら辺は心の働きで
ただ入れたものは中で分解してエネルギー取って
要らないものは捨てちゃうということは機械的な働きであって
そういうふうに考えると
皆様方に分かりやすく
心って何ものかと理解できるはずなんですね
なんでその定義がそんなに延々と言いますかというと
仏教というのはすごく具体的で科学的で合理的であるということは
特に釈迦の教えが 僕はずっと言ってるんだから
そのことですよと 例えば心というのは尊いものですよとか
そういう大雑把な言葉はありません
人間の もう何て言いますか
ありがたいものは魂ですよ
心ですよというふうに
そういうありがたいってどういう意味かとかね
我々は聞きたくなっちゃう
尊いってどういう意味ですかとかね
あるいは人間に授けられているのは
まあそれは心ですよ 魂ですよとか
またヨーロッパだったら動物は命ですけど
魂はないんだと 人間にはだけは魂があるんだと
どこに証拠があるんですかと
我々仏教徒は聞きたくなるんですね
私たちから見れば 動物も人間も何も差がないんですけど
だけどそこら辺は宗教の世界で信じているんですね
人間には魂を吹き込んでもらったと
動物にはないんだと でも僕らから見
私たちから見れば やっぱり動物も我々と同じく感情を持ってるんですね
豚は食べるために作られていた
感謝して食べなくちゃいけないんだと
せっかく美味しい豚作ってくれましたからと言うながら
でも豚は殺すと逃げちゃうんですね
それで痛くて泣くんですね
本当に豚は悲しく泣くんですね
人間と同じく そんなにありがたく
人間の食うために作ったものだったら
人間殺そうとしていると
やっと私の出番も出ましたと
晴れ舞台が出ましたと思ってありがたく殺されていただくはずなんですけど
そうじゃないでしょ 一生懸命逃げようとしている
ですから 怖さやら愛情やら欲やら怒りやら
そういうものは豚にも鶏にも魚にもあるんです
ですから 仏教から見れば同じじゃないかと
そこで客観的に見ると
物体がある 人間作った機械みたいな働きがある
機械がある それで生命体がある
この生命体に この物体と機械と区別できる働きが心の働きであって
そういう点では犬猫にも虫にも微生物にも心がちゃんとあるということはご理解できると思います
微生物に本当に心があるんですかと
やっぱり心があると言っちゃ疑うのは魂があるんですかという概念で考えるんだから
でも生命体として見ると
もうちゃんと頑張ってる
ものすごい人間より賢くて鋭くて
このウイルスとか よくも人間の体に乗っ取ってね
私たちをもう支配してもうやってるんだから
ですから 別に人間みたいに頭で考えてないかもしれませんだけど
なんとかこの自分の命をどんどんどんどん増やして続けたいという
この生命としての働きはそこにきちんとあるんですね
特にウイルスの場合は
DNA はもう完全じゃないんですね
一部しか持ってない それ自分一人では何にもできないんですね
そこで他の生命を侵さないと
他の DNA を侵さないと
なかなかもう自分の命は成り立たない
それちゃんと計算して
今知ってる 今大変人気のあるエイズウイルスにしたっても
あれすごい賢いんですね
自分の DNA 入らずに変化するんですね
攻撃されないようにと
それで一番T細胞ですから
もう全部食ってしまっちゃいますから
じゃあ自分がT細胞の中に入ってそれを侵しちゃえばどうですかと
そうすると生き延びるのはよく考えるもんなんですね
それは人間の言葉に入れると考えることになりますけど
別に考えることはなくたっても
やっぱり生命としてちゃんとした働きなんですね
その生命としての働きは心であると
それは第1番目の講義でもう言ったことなんですね
たった 5 分でまとめたのはそういうことで
2時間かかってくだらないこと言ったでしょうと思いますけど
で 第2番目の講義で言ったことをまたまとめて申し上げると
この物体の支配者誰ですかと
体物体で見ましょう その物体の支配者は誰ですかというと
生命という働きなんですね
心という働きなんですね
物体としてもう何もできないんですね
捨てたらならば捨てたまんまで
そのまんまなんですね
でも我々は動いたり 考えたり
行動したり 喧嘩したり
仲良くしたりする 建物を作ったり
勉強したり 仕事をしたりする
いろんなことをなさってるんですね
そういうのは全部生命としての働きだから
心の働きである そうすると我々はっていうのは
やっぱり結局心であって物体ではないんですね
だから心があるんだから
生命としているんだから
我々は服を着る おしゃれをする
人間と喋る 考える ですから
そういうすべてが一番大事なんですね
別に体はそんなに大事なわけじゃないんです
体という物体が大事なわけじゃないんです
心があるんだから そういうのは大事であって
ですから 僕は 2番目で言ったのは
体っていうのは心の単なる道具に過ぎないんだと
私は歩きたいんですね
そこで心 生命としてのエネルギーで歩けないんですね
それで足を使って歩く
歩くんですね ですから
心が足を動かしちゃう
で 心が喋りたい でも心には喋れないんですね
それでこの体の発声器官を使って喋らせちゃう
ですから 心が言いたいものは全部この機械では言えなくなっちゃうんですね
たまに皆様忙しくて早く行きたい
気持ちとしては瞬時に行きたいんだけど
心は体を道具として使ってるんだから
足で行かなくちゃいけないんだから
それでもう時間かかってしまっちゃう
例えば私は申し上げたいことはいっぱい頭の中にあるんだけど
この言葉とか口とか喉とか空気とか使わなくちゃいけないんですね
それで言いたいものは全部言えなくなっちゃうんですね
皆様もそういう経験毎日味わっていると思いますよ
伝えたい気持ちはあるんだけど
うまく言えないと  1時間ぐらいあの人と喋ったんだけど
でもまだまだ言いたいこといっぱいありましたと
仕事は早く 30分で終わりたいんだけど
なかなか 2時間もかかったそうと
ですから その心の規模と
この道具として体の鈍さですか
そちらのこの問題なんですね
あの 初めて作ったコンピューターも同じです
それほど今のものとか同じく
このあまり機能はないんですね
それほどスピードもないんですね
ですから すごい時間をかけて
ゆっくりゆっくり決まってる単純な仕事しかしてもらうことができなかったんです
その時も人々はいろんなことをできればいいないいなと思ってたんだけど
前のもうもっと一世代前のコンピューターではそんなもの何もできなかったんですね
それで機械は優れていなかったんだから
ですから 機械は優れてくると
その分働きはやってくる
だから我々の体もものすごく優れてくるならば
心のスピードでいろんなことをやってくれるかもしれませんだけど
でも体っていうのはそんなに早く進化するものでもないんですね
そこで一つ理解してほしいなのは
心の規模 いわゆる生命として我々はやりたいことはいっぱいあるんだけど
どうも体としてやらなくちゃいけない
体はそんな自由自在がない物体ですから
そこでどうしてもギャップが起こる
起こるんですね 英語で言えばあるコンフランテーション
コンフリクトがコンフリクトが起こるんですね
いつでもそれを感じていらっしゃるでしょう
だから 気持ちでやりたいものはいっぱいあるんだけど
例えばいくら私たちが年取ったっても
若者と同じく走り回りたいでしょうに
でもできないんですね
そこですごく悔しいんですね
そこで あの みんなと若者と同じく面白い話をして
よく笑ったり ニコニコと明るく楽しく生活したいのは心の気持ちなんですけど
やっぱり体は許してくれない
腰が痛いし もうひどい
腸が悪いし 心臓が弱いし
高血圧はあるし それでもなかなか若者みたく動けなくなっちゃう
そこで あの この 何て言いますか
ぶつかっちゃうんですね
心にとってはもうなんかめんどくさいというかね
体の働きは 人間の悩みというのはそこに大体生まれるんですね
希望はいっぱいあるんだけど
その希望がどうも叶うというか
その希望通りに行くということはなかなかうまくいかない
それでギャップが生まれてきて
例えば 1 日中働きたいんだけど
体は疲れてしまっちゃう
そこですごく不満と悔しさが生まれてくる
走りたいんだけど なかなか体がついてこない
そこで不安やらいろんなものがついてくる
オリンピックとか そういう選手たちを育てる時もよくわかることは
ほとんどこの心理的な方が一番多いんですね
ただ体あるんだからといって
上手なスポーツマンになるわけじゃないんですね
そこでコーチたちがきちんと精神的な指導をいっぱいするんですね
そこでテレビで見ている時は
このオリンピックの選手なんか見ていると
精神 この並んでいる人々の中で一番精神的に落ち着いている人が勝つんですね
他の記録はどうであろうと
過去の記録 それに関係なく
大体計算上統計上 あの人は金メダル取るよとみんな思ってるんだけど
もうどこかでこけてしまっちゃうんですね
ですから あの あの 何て言いますか
あの音が聞こえる瞬間で
その人たちの顔を見てください
みんなこの準備している瞬間で
スタートするために そこで落ち着いている人とちょっと心配の人と見えちゃうんですね
何のことなく冷静で落ち着いている人が金メダル取っちゃうんです
なぜならば体力みんな同じだから
もう人間のギリギリのところで戦っているんだから
それだったら勝負は精神の世界に残って
心の世界に残っちゃうんですね
ですから この我々のこの精神的な問題とか
それは心と体のこの ギャップで生まれてくるものなんですね
体はあくまでも純粋に物質として働いてくれる
機械として 心はそれでは満足しない
納得いかない そういうことで人間のギャップが生まれてくる
それから心というのは体の支配者
体 心のためにあるものであって
ということ これ 第2番目の講義の内容なんですね
えーと 心の支配者だから
自分の奴隷だから 体が
結局は心が作ったものなんです
皆様方はお金あると電車に乗るのめんどくさいんだと
楽しく楽にいろんなところに行きたいと思っちゃうと車買うんですね
ですから 車の支配者所有者が皆様買った人なんですね
ですから その自分の車
どうしたってもその人の勝手であって
でも車自分で買うんだからといって
どんな車でも買えるわけないんですね
自分のこの購買力というのは
買える力っていうのもまたあるんですね
日本車買うか 外車買うか
高級車買うか 一般の軽自動車買うかという
自分の駐車場の問題とか
いろいろことで制限されちゃうんですね
早く行きたいと言ったっても
世界でものすごい速い車があるんですね
あるんだけど だからといって買えるわけでもないんですね
ものすごい高級車に乗りたいと言ったっても
みんな片っ端からロールスロイス
車とか買えるわけじゃないんですね
いろいろ条件があるんですね
ですから せっかく自分のために買う車だから
自分の希望通りのものを買っちゃえばいいのに
それはうまくいかない
いろんな条件でどんな車買うべきかということはもう決まられてしまっちゃうんです
そういうふうに心が自分で体が決まったならば
自分思い存分行動できる体作っちゃえばいいでしょ
そこがちょっと難しいんですね
車と同じく ですから 心は自分持っているエネルギーにふさわしい体を持ってるんですね
ですから 弱い体があって
強い体がある 美しい体があって
美しくない体がある 病弱な体があって
もう全然病気は効かない体もあるっていう風になっちゃうんです
それからもう一つ 一番そのポイントよりもっと大事なポイントっていうのは
いつでも心の影響を体にあるっていうことなんです
車と同じなんですね 車はやっぱり所有者の性格は車に映りますから
本当にしっかりしている人だったら車をきちんとしっかりしているし
泥はないし ちゃんと洗ってワックスかけて
中はちゃんと掃除して
いろいろきれいないろんなものを入れたりして
大変雰囲気が良くて いい加減な人だったら中は泥だらけで砂だらけでもう喫煙タバコの吸い殻とかもういろいろそういう状態なんですね
そこで本当に性格はいい人が買った車は長持ちするし
性格の良くない人が買う車が早くもう悪くなって使えなくなったりするし
心の場合も同じく 心は体に影響を与えている
そこでとんでもないいい加減な心だったら
その人の体も同じくいい加減なものになっちゃうんです
もし心がわがままだったら
体もわがままなんでいい加減なんで言って言ってることやってくれないんですね
あるでしょ たまに人が歩いたんだけど
腰が痛いと 膝が痛いと
疲れると 息切れになるんだと
でも気持ちとしてはそうなりたくないんです
やっぱりその人の性格心がすごいわがままなんです
そういうふうに心が体をいろいろコントロールして
あの 何て言いますか 影響を与えている
逆もあるんです 体のせいで心が影響を受けるということもあるんですね
それ 車の場合も同じことなんですね
なんかまあ 車はものすごくゆっくり走る車だったら
人はまあそのスピードに合わせなくちゃいけないんですね
いくら隣の他の人はもう高速道路でサッと行ったんだから
私もやってやるぞと思って
いくら踏んでやっても
もう遅い車は遅いんだからスピードは出さないし
そこですごいボロ車だったら
そのボロ車に乗った人も気持ちもそのボロになってしまっちゃうし
もう高級車に乗ってる人々は余計に何か威張ってるんじゃないですか
すごいかっこつけて まあその姿勢にそうなっちゃうんですね
ですから 我々の体の場合も
体がすごい元気で活発的になっちゃうと
心も明るく元気に活発的になってしまっちゃう
体が病気になってくると
心もどんどんどんどん病気になって暗くなって沈んでしまっちゃうという
お互いに影響を与えるということはあるんです
ですから 体が心を支配していて
心 間違った心が体を支配しているし
でも心も体の影響を受けて自分の自由を失っているし
そのポイントは我々には大変必要なポイントなんです
だから仏教という宗教は
そういう風に人間の幸福を科学的に
具体的に 論理的に喋るんですね
お祈りしろというふうな教えではない
それだけ僕はいつでもとことんとことん言ってる
言ってあげてるものなんですね
だから 他の宗教と同じく
我々も人間は幸福で 明るく平和で生きていてほしいと
それから もし死んでも来世があるならば
来世も幸福で生きていてほしいという希望はあるんです
その点では 宗教は誰でも同じ気持ちがあって
それで方法論として我々はこういう風な心と体の働きを教えてあげて
それに何とかしてくださいとということだけ違うところなんですね
ですから そこら辺 我々大事なポイントで
もし人がずっと体が言うことを聞いてくれないと思うならば
そこら辺長い間心の働きがいい加減であったことの結果なんですね
長い間暗い心で生きていたならば
必ずしも体はその結果を受けて影響を受けて
大変暗い結果出してくれる
それから いくら明るく元気で頑張ろうとしても
例えば年取ってくると
ずっと若い時は明るい人は年取ってきたっても
年になっても明るく行動したいんですね
それでも体はもう老化しているんだから
なかなかついてこない
そうすると精神的にも年取ってしまっちゃうんですね
ちょっと歩いてみようと思ったところで
まあ息切れになっちゃって
心臓はドキドキするわ
もう血圧は高くなるわ
もうどうしようもないと
止めますと休んじゃうんですね
そうすると心もやっぱりダメだと
自分があっちこっち外に外で運動するよりはね
まあどこかで座っておせんべいでも食べながらテレビ見た方がいいんじゃないかと思ったりして
心も年取ってしまっちゃうんですね
その場合は 本当は心には年がないんです
年あるのは体だけなんです
心はこの時間空間にはあんまり気にしない
時間空間と関係なく働くんですね
ですから 皆様の歳いくつかと聞いたら
皆様はこの世で生まれた日から計算して言うんであって
気持ちの中にはないんです
歳は 何歳かと 歳の人であろうが
二十歳の人であろうが
気持ちとしては歳がないんです
歳あるのは体だけなんです
それもまあ 心には歳がない
時空 時間間 時間 空間関係
時空関係も持たない それでも体の影響を受けて心も弱くなるわ
年取るわ そうすると老化現象ものすごい早くなっちゃうんです
そこで私はここで言いたいことは
ポイントはこういうポイントなんですね
もし明るい心で行動すると
確実に心も明るくじゃなくて軽くなるんです
柔軟性を持てるようになっちゃうんです
逆に心が体が柔軟性を持てるように
すごく軽くしておけば
健康的にしておけば 心もその影響で健康的になっちゃうんですね
それは女性の中でよく見えることなんですね
いろいろダイエットなんかして
大変成功して 素晴らしいプロポーションに戻っちゃったら
まあ気持ちいいことをみんな
今まで暗くてああだこうだ文句ばっかり言ってる人でも
元気になっちゃって もうすごい活発になって行動し始めちゃうんです
それはどういうことかというと
体の調子が良くなってきたんだから
もう心の調子も良くなってくる
それダイエット中なんか喋ってみちゃったら
もう何言うかわからない
怒られるんです 自分がもうダイエット中だから
食べたいんだけど我慢して食べていないんだから
その怒りは我々にも男性の方にぶつかったりするし
でももしそれ成功したところで体重を量ってみて
プロポーションを測ってみたところで
OK だと すごいんですよと
もう綺麗な服着られますよと言われたら
あんな苛立ち状態はすぐ消えちゃうんですね
性格も変わるんですね
なんか最近コマーシャルありますね
なんか性格まで変わっちゃいますよと
あれはコマーシャルで冗談で言ってますけど
これは本当は事実なんです
性格まで変わっちゃうんです
体きちんともうピッタシときちんとしたならば
性格まで変わっちゃう
そこで心がきちっとしているならば
当然体もきちんとしちゃうんです
その総合的な効果がありまして
そこで我々に何ができるのはそこら辺なんですね
そこで育てるならば どっち育てた方がいいんですか？というと
優先的に言えるのは心を育てなさいと
なぜならば体は単なる機械だから
単なる道具だから それはいつか捨てますから
道具だからもう時間切れになったら捨てるんだから
体を育ててもいつか捨てなくちゃいけない
ですから 優先順番で言うならば
心が育てる方が優先であって
唯一ね ものなんですね
でもそれ難しいというならば
じゃあ心から体から頑張ってみてくださいと
体はしっかりするようにしてみなさいと
そうすると心がしっかりする
それから心を育てることはできるんです
で 今日はこれから今日の話に戻ります
それは第2番目の講義の一応簡単な話なんです
その心の育て方 この優先的に言えば心なんですね
体の育ち方を私が言っちゃうと
なんかもう関係ない人が関係ないことを喋ることになっちゃうんですね
なんか床屋さんが手術外科の先生の講義をするような感じで
もういい加減にしろと言った状態なんですね
例えば心の育ち方だったら
皆様もうご存知ご存知事で
運動だったらその人に聞けばいいし
栄養のことだったら栄養士に聞けばいいし
病気のことだったらお医者さんに聞けばいいし
それはそれで結構ですからね
私に聞かなくてもいいんです
もうちゃんとちゃんと体力つけてほしいと思って
エアロビクスやりたいならば
エアロビクス指導者に聞けばいいんです
私に聞いたってもわかりません
やったことはないんだから
ですから私は心の世界の人々だから
心の育ち方というところからだけお話しさせていただきます
で 今日は一応あの このプラス思考とマイナス思考ですか
ネガティブ思考とプラス思考とネガティブ思考という両方を説明したいんです
で これをまず覚えておいてください
心が働く瞬間瞬間 体に影響を与えるんです
いつでも 常に 常に心が体に影響を与えつつなんです
それは法則です もう皆様方
理解してもしなくても
それには関係なく法則なんです
瞬間瞬間の心の働きが
我々の体に瞬間瞬間影響を与えつつですということ
それ真面目に考えると大変危ないことなんです
まあ説明いたしますが
例えば我々は目を開けていろんなものを見る
見るたびに体に影響が入っちゃうんです
それわかるのは いきなりものすごい面白い美しいものを見たと
見た瞬間に体中喜びが湧いてきて
明るくなってしまっちゃうんですね
例えば すぐ疲れて疲れますよという人でも
面白いところに行っちゃったら
それを言わないんですね
忘れちゃうんです 遊ぶところに行っちゃったら
何のことなく遊んじゃうんですね
ということは 面白いところに行ったんだから
自分の気に入っているところに行ったんだだから歩けない腰も痛いし
ああだこうだ文句言ってる人さえ
すぐ心の影響を受けて
体が影響を受けてもう行動するようになっちゃうんです
ですから それは誰でも経験している事実なんです
ものすごい見たくない酷いことを見ちゃったら
いきなり体も驚いちゃって
気持ち悪くなっちゃって
体が悪くなってしまっちゃうんです
それは大胆なことではなくて
ただこの部屋を見ても同じことで
この部屋の雰囲気によって体はサッと変化する
皆様 この講義終わったらもう出かけますね
出かけたら 外へ出た瞬間で
その雰囲気によって体がもう変わってしまっちゃうんです
違うものになっちゃうんです
そこで歩いて駅まで歩くとなんか狭い空間歩いていかなくちゃいけないでしょうに
その時はそれなりに体の雰囲気も変わってしまっちゃうんです
券売機のところに行っちゃったら
また体も心も変わっちゃうし
ホームに乗っちゃったらまた違うし
電車に乗っちゃったらまた変わっちゃうし
恐ろしい速さで体が変化していくんです
それほとんど認めないんですね
普通の人々は でも俺は俺ではないかと
そうじゃないんです そうじゃないんです
いつでも変化しているんです
ですから 瞬間瞬間 我々の心が変化する
見る 聞く 味わう 考えると同時に体も影響を受けて変化する
そこで何が危ないかというと
私たちは口では言わないんだけど
頭の中でいろんな危ないことを考えているんですね
口では言わない 口では大変素晴らしく
行儀よく品格よく喋ったり行動したりはする
でも頭は別に回転させちゃうんですね
例えば誰か人に会う時は
ちゃんと礼儀正しく挨拶をして
大変丁寧な言葉を交わしちゃったりして
もう言葉上はものすごくうまくその会話は終わるんですが
その人のこと本当は気に入らない場合は
心の中でやっぱりこの人は私は気に入らないなという気持ちが回転しているんですね
この人早く帰ってくれませんかとか
気持ちは向こうの中でもう回転している場合あるんですね
その場合は見てください
その人は帰った瞬間 体にストレス溜まってるんですね
疲れるんですね なぜかというと
心で暗い思考を回転させていたんです
嫌な思考 嫌という 嫌という感覚を味わっていたんですね
それだったら嫌という感覚を体も味わえなくちゃいけないんです
そこで体に物質的な変化さえ起こるんですね
やっと最近テレビで私はずっと前からもう考えて誰にも言わなかった意見があって
テレビで出たんです 糖尿病なんかは全部この精神的な問題だと
ストレスの原因だと 僕らは仏教の連中は昔からそんなことはあなた方は落ち着いてないんだから
まあ性格が悪くて病気になるだけではないかと
いわゆる不安定で不安
神感でストレスばっかり溜まっちゃって
だから病気になるんだと
糖尿病になるんだと 糖尿病になる方々っていうのは
いつでもどこかで落ち着きがない
不安定 だからこの大体落ち着きがなくなっちゃったら
不安定になったら この男性だったらすぐタバコ吸ったりする
今は日本の場合は女性の方が多いんだけど
タバコを吸う方々は で
それも僕は当たり前の現象だと思います
昔は女性はそんな大胆なことをするなという文化もあったんだけど
今はそうじゃないんだから
いっぱいストレス溜まってるんですね
そこですっごくタバコ吸ったりする
それ同じくこの食べちゃうんですね
この人々は で 食べても体がそれを正しく消化しない
なぜならば 正しく消化するために体は正しく動かなくちゃいけないんですね
体が正しく動く動くためにも
運転手が正しく運転しなくちゃいけないんですね
運転手が心だから 心がいい加減だから
だからこのただこの自分が好きで
砂糖ばっかり入ってる食べ物ばっかり食べていても
糖尿病にはならないんです
それはデータがちゃんとあるんです
このホームレスの方々とか
日本だけではなくて このアメリカとかにもいるし
食べるものは全部体に悪いものなんですね
あっちこっちから拾って
このこのジャンクフードですか
そればっかり食べてるんですね
それでもこのホームレスの中でもこの専業というんですか
この それ専業としてホームレスになってる人々いるんですね
別に仕事をしたいんだったらするんです
できるんです ものすごい頭がいいんです
ある人はもう石油会社のこのマネージングやっていた人で
ドイツで もう博士号 2つ持っていて
だからもうすごい人なんです
ものすごい高い給料といえば
もうすごい給料もらっていて
いきなり仕事嫌になっちゃって
ホームレスになっちゃったんです
奥さんも腹が立ってもう離婚したし
彼がもう着てない服を着て
まあホームレスで生活してるんです
全部捨てて だからちょっと喋ってみちゃった
テレビでもその人と喋ったのを聞いていたんです
すごいんですよ 頭なんかは
そういうふうに自分の気持ちよく
この生き方いいんだと
何もストレスなく 楽しく
責任もなく 毎日毎日生きていればいいんじゃないかという気持ちになったんだから
そういう人々食べるものはほとんどもうもうどこかから拾ったものなんです
でもその場合はコレステロールも上がらないし
糖尿病にもならないんですね
でも 嫌だな ホームレスの人生っていうのは
本当はしっかり生きていきたいなと
でもしょうがないなという気持ちで言っている人々は
やれ糖 糖尿病とコレステロール全部なるんです
そういうのはもうちゃんとしたデータがあるんです
集めたデータが 僕ではなくて
このアメリカの方にヨーロッパの方
ですから やっぱり心は一番大事なとこなんですね
ですから 人は菓子パンやらあんこ入ってるものやら
もう毎日食べたって もうだから糖尿病になるということじゃないんです
すごく気持ちよく落ち着いていて
何もストレスなく 自分の好物はこういうものだから
こればっかし食ってますよと言っても
それは問題ない 体ちゃんと知ってるんで
それはどうやって分解すればいいかということ
心が落ち着いていると
だからどんな食べ物でも食べる時はストレスなく
気持ちよく 明るい気持ちで
これは美味しいんだと
これは私の好物だからと
思って食べてみると ちゃんと体がそれなりに変化して
体に悪い影響を与えないようにするんです
それは問題ないんです
ですから 私たち知ってほしいのは
心がおかしくなっちゃったら
体も確実におかしくなっちゃうんです
それで瞬間瞬間の考え方
この大事なんです なぜならば
1年間の考え方が大事かというと
1年間でも我々が考えてるのは瞬間瞬間だから
ですから 瞬間瞬間の考え方を気をつけてほしい
瞬間でも暗い考え方 ネガティブな考え方
否定的な考え方は危ない
それはやめた方がいいです
すぐやめればすぐそこからもう幸福の世界生まれてくるんです
明るい思考に戻れば 体も治っちゃうし
心も治っちゃうし それからさらに心を育てることもできるし
最後のテーマでは この心の
何でしたっけ この超越法と書いてましたから
そこもできるようになっちゃうんです
で じゃあ問題は 仏教っていうのはもうちゃんと具体的に何が何ですかと言わなきゃ仏教的じゃないんだから
じゃあネガティブ思考って何ですか？ポジティブ思考って何ですかとはっきりと知っておかなきゃ
またもうごちゃ混ぜになっちゃうんですね
自分勝手に 私はこれはネガティブ思考だと思いますよ
これはポジティブ思考だと思いますよ
自分勝手に思っちゃってもダメなんです
それはちゃんとした科学的な事実でなければ
ですから ネガティブ思考は全ての生命に対してネガティブ思考でなければいけません
人間だけではなくて ポジティブ思考は全ての生命に対してポジティブ思考でなければいけません
そこら辺 少々説明してみようと
で その前に心の基本的な働きがございまして
ネガティブともポジティブとも言えない
生命として心としての基本的な働きがあるんです
それをまず理解しておきましょう
で 仏教では13種類に分けてますが
そういうのはちゃんと明確に
でも13種類は理解するためにはもうかなり深い理解必要になっちゃいますから
いくらかわかりやすいところだけいくらかは説明します
で 一つはこのパーリ語でサンニャーというんです
で 日本語ではちょっと日本語の感じがありますけど
なかなかこの意味は入ってないと思いますけど
想と書きますけどね それは仏教用語でただの漢字だけなんです
あんまり深く考えなくたっていいんです
[咳]この想というこの漢字を分解してみると意味が分かりになる可能性もありますけど
不思議なことで これはこの
なんかこの記憶みたいなものなんです
記憶でもないんです なんか変なものなんです
こういうことなんです
で 皆様がもう私をもうよく見ていらっしゃるんですね
そこで私は 例えば他のところで見たならば
すぐわかるでしょう あの人やと
そのその場合は 心はこういう働きするんですね
この私の体から体に入ったデータをあって
それを何とか結論作る
この結果だよと それでその結果とこの記憶から似ている何か体験と当てはめてみる
あなたはこれに当てはまりますよと
それからそれにどんな言葉するんですか？と言葉から一つ当てはめてみる
当てはめて あ これはスマナサーラですよと決めちゃう
瞬時に起こるんです それは
そのこの頭の中で この認識認識プロセスを起こるために
この想という基本的なデータ必要なんです
それは一回目で生まれるんです
いわゆるこういうこと
生まれて初めてある人に顔を合わせる
この目を開けて その人の見た瞬間で
その人についての想一つ頭の中に入っちゃうんです
もう二番目に見ると もう当たり前でもうわかっちゃうんですね
それ何回何回繰り返すと記憶になっちゃうんです
一回目では記憶にはなりませんだけど
でもデータだけはちゃんと残っちゃうんです
そのデータは決してはっきりしているデータではないんです
すごい基本的なものなんです
ですから 記憶でもないんです
記憶っていうのは  1956年で
私はなんとかなんとか
ところでなんとかなんとかしていましたというふうな
この現象的なものなんですね
想っていうのはもっと基本的なもので
それを私たちはいつでも作ってるんです
そういうのはネガティブでもポジティブでもないんです
まあどうしようもないものなんです
それはどうせ必要なんです
で 例えば何かご飯でも何でも食べたところで美味しいですよと言うでしょ
それはどういうことかというと
これはちょっと美味しくないよと言うんですね
自分がこの美味しいという概念
生まれて初めて作った瞬間があるんです
生まれて初めて その時
何か食べたりした瞬間で
頭に入った想を尺度にして美味しいかないかと決めるんです
なんか全く何とコンピューターと同じことをやってるんです
別に だから人間にとってはおいしいという概念
様々バラバラなんですね
だから私は美味しいと言ったんだからといって
皆様方に美味しいというわけにはならないんです
[背景音楽]外国の食べ物でも美味しいというのが
自分ち初めて小さい時食べた似ている味のものに似ている時だけなんです
そうでないと美味しくないというものです
ですから これ説明する場合は
仏教ではこのマークサインという言葉も使っちゃうんですね
お印お印と何か見ると何かお印をつけちゃう
何か聞くとすぐ印をする
それはそうと読むんですね
だからこの層の上のものはだいたいその意味なんです
お印マークという意味なんです
下は心ですから それ心のことやと
これを思いという漢字でも読みますけどね
でもそれは日本語だから思いと読む場合は漢字じゃないんですね
だから仏教の漢字言葉っていうのは
ただの漢字だけ言葉ではないんです
中国語でもないんです
専門用語 ですから この漢字
これは思いということではないかと勘違いしたら困るんです
日本であるいろんな仏教の本では
もうほとんど間違ってるんですね
仏教解釈は 私はもう合ってるという言えば
このものすごい立派な
もう大先生たちがものすごい真剣に真面目に書いてる
科学的に学問的に書いてる本以外はもう全然もうダメと言っても構いません
なぜかというと 日本語で読んじゃうんですね
仏教用語 この般若心経とかね
解釈あるとこうすごいたくさんあるんです
私が読むと笑っちゃうんです
何言ってるんです？さっぱりわかってないでしょうと
あれはもう日本語で読んじゃうんだから
漢字 漢字で読むか日本語で読むか
じゃあそれは字だけなんです
ですから 意味は別にちゃんとした伝統の中から教えてもらわなくちゃ困るんです
国語辞典引いちゃったら困るんです
ですから 宋の場合も 国語辞典引いても仏教の意味は言ってくれません
仏教ではこの普通の人間は全然気がつかない
この心の基本的な働き
それを我々はスーッと作りっぱなし
この印見る見るものに印を作る
たまに間違うでしょ 人の後ろ姿を見て
あれ田中さんではないかと思って
ちょっと待ってくださいと言ったら
顔を見たらすいません
違う人違いでしたという場合もあるでしょ
それはその層の働きなんです
そうはあれ あの あの田中さんだよと
いわゆる入る情報似てるんですね
後ろ姿から田中さんの後ろ姿から入った層と
今見た人の後ろの姿から入った層があまりも似てるんだから
あ これの言葉は田中ですよと思う
そうすると 田中さんの顔と田中さんの性格と全部つなげて田中さんだよと決めてくれる
そういう風に見たら田中さんではなかったと
そういう層の間違いはもう毎日いっぱいあるんです
毎日いっぱいあるんです
皆様方はどうかわかりませんだけど
僕らにはあるんだけど
例えば暗闇の中でロープのロープなんか見たら
僕らはものすごくびっくりして立ち上がっちゃうんです
すごく怖くなっちゃって
ヘビだとびっくりするんです
もうもし噛まれたら 踏んじゃったらもう命ないんだから
でもロープはロープだから踏んだってもどっちでもいいんだけど
あれは何ですかというと
ヘビとヘビの層とロープの層がほとんど似ているんですね
そこでそう見た瞬間でもうヘビだと決めちゃう
決めちゃったらもう心臓がドキドキして
びっくりして立ち上がる
もう飛んじゃうちゃうん
飛んじゃうんです 昨日も同じ経験僕にあったんです
外へちょっと出たんです
出たらなんかでっかい長いものが道路の暗いところにあったんですね
あったら僕はあんまり
このまあバカだから何見たってあんまり怖がらないんですね
すごい鈍いんです で あれ
ヘビじゃないかと思った
それでもあれ ヘビじゃないか
その瞬間でこんな辺でヘビいるわけないでしょうと
またって見たらベルトなんですね
誰かの何か荷物をつなげる人のベルトではなくて
長いベルト 何か落ちてあって
あれを見たらものすごい長いんだけど
僕は長いヘビは見たことがありますから
いきなりヘビじゃないかと
またその瞬間にあ 日本のヘビはいるわけない
他のものでしょうと思って見たところで
ベルトであったんだけど
その瞬間でこの例 また思い出しちゃったんですね
我々の伝統的に このロープを見てヘビだと間違うではないかという
だから その世界で我々はよく間違いは起こすんです
もうちょっと明確に見ると
あのそうじゃなくて これだよと
違う相を当ててみる そういう風に我々の認識形でいつでも相はいっぱい作る
同じ相を何回繰り返すと
それは記憶になっちゃう
だから人の名前でも人の顔でも勉強でも
何回何回繰り返すと もうしっかりと覚えておきますのは
そういう働きなんです
そういうのは基本的な働き
相にはちょっと時間がかかりすぎでしたから
まず次に行きます もう一つは
この意思 チェータナというのです
パーリ語でチェータナと言うんですね
日本語の意味は意思なんですね
意思でしょうかね まあ仏教漢字では志だけ書いてますけど
あの仏教漢字ではただの志ですか
こんな漢字 それだけ書いてますけどね
ちょっと汚いんだけど
で その場合もこの思う漢字ですから
思うということで理解しちゃったらまた困っちゃうんです
全然その意味じゃないんです
意思なんです 意思というのはすごい基本的な働きで
いつでも私たち の心の中で何かしたいというこの気持ちがあるんですね
いつでもあるでしょう
何かしたいと 見たい 聞きたい
歩きたいとか ずっとある働きなんです
何もしたくないというのは何もしたくないという意思なんです
それもう絶対なくならないものなんです
私は何もしたくない もうずっと寝たいというのも同じ意思
止まりません それにはネガティブでもポジティブでも何のこともないんです
でもこの意思の場合は
ちょっと問題はこの意思があるんだから行動しているんです
生きているんです ですから
生きていることの大変基本的なわけなんです
仏教で業というのは 業という言葉知ってますね
カルマ 業というのはこの意思なんです
この日本で皆様の耳に入っているこの変な意味じゃないんです
業が悪い人ですよとか
ああだこうだとかね 業の深い人やとか
そういう意味じゃないんです
きちんとした心理学的なことで
それ意思 働きたいという気持ち
それで我々の運命全部決めちゃいますから
何をしたいかということは
もうそこで道がもう決めてしまっちゃうんです
そういうのはいいことでも悪いことでもないものなんです
基本的にあるもの で もう一つ全部説明できません
えーと あ これも覚えときましょう
これもちょっと覚えておきましょう
あの心の講義だから まあいろいろ心の特色を勉強した方がいいと思う
これはエクッガターと読むんです
で 五法です これは一教
はい 一応訳としては一境性という感じの感じで
言ってますが この集中力と似ているんです
集中力っていうのは ある長い時間
何か一つのものをやれるということですね
集中力っていうのは で
同じことなんです どんな瞬間にも心に本当は集中力あるんです
ただ 長い時間同じことをやらないんだから
あなたに集中力は何もないんではないかと我々怒りますけど
でも集中力はどんな生命にもごく普通に基本的にあるものなんです
問題は いろんなものに集中するんだから
我々は集中力ないやつだなと怒るだけのことなんです
本も開けといて テレビも見ているし
またせんべいも食べているし
また足もぶらぶら動かしたりしているし
だから落ち着きがないんだと
それは落ち着きがないんじゃなくて
短い時間でたくさんのことをやっているということなんです
もし足も動かさないで
テレビも見ないで ラジオも聞かないで
せんべいも食べないで
ずっと30分ぐらい本を読んでとなれば
集中力がある人やと言うんですね
それは一般的な話で 本当は瞬間瞬間
誰にでもこの集中力というものはあるんです
ですから ということは
我々は何か見る瞬間でそれだけ見ているんです
聞く瞬間でそれちょっと聞いてるんです
次他のことをやるかもしれませんよ
その時はそれに集中しちゃうんです
仏教でも言うのは このあっちこっちあっちこっち集中力を失っちゃうと
何一つも真面目にやりくはないんですね
いわゆるモノにならないんですね
いわゆるもう30秒本を読む
30秒もう掃除をする
また30秒テレビを聞いている見ているとか
また30秒 また30秒本を読むと
どっちもやったことにならないちゃうんですね
本読んだって何読んだかわからなくなっちゃうし
ですからこれモノにならないんですね
ですから 集中力は育てるべきなんですね
いわゆる一つのものを長い時間認識するということ
育てた方が大変役に立ちます
そこで瞑想ではこのとことん集中力ということを育てちゃうんですね
それはすごい力が強くなったところで
我々はサマーディという言葉を使っているんです
その時は仏教では定というと違う言葉使ってますけど
定ですね うん 定めですか
ですね でも結局定という漢字が定めという意味ではないんです
ただ 一つのものにきちんとついていられるという心が
すごい気持ちいい状態なんですけど
じゃあそういうふうな心の基本的な働き
まだたくさんあります
で 次にあの名前だけ あまり説明すると時間なくなります
なくなりますので名前だけ言いますけど
あのヴィタッカヴィチャーナって 2つの言葉ありまして
この心 心 心と  ここに見えるところです
この二つ これ二つの働きなんですね
漢字は漢字で結構ですけど
意味は私にはわかりませんだけど
この漢字の で どういう意味かというと
この わかりやすいのはこの考えることと似ているものなんですね
物事を考えたり それについてちょっと探して調べたりというふうな
この心の基本的な働き
いわゆる言葉でいろんなものを考えるんじゃなくて
例えばちょっとこれ見たっても
なんか見た瞬間で これずっと見て
なんか研究ようなことやっちゃうんです
見た瞬間 いわゆる思考と似ているんです
大雑把に言えば 追求とは違うんだけど
同じことの追求というと時間すごくかかっちゃうんですね
これに時間かけない 瞬間には起こるんです
この瞬間に起こることは
長い時間でいうと追求することであって
思考である 例えば長い時間これ見ていると
これはどんなメーカーで作ったものですか？とか
どれぐらい古いんですか？とかね
いろいろ出てくるんです
でも 瞬間にもその働きはあるんです
だから人間には思考もありますし
追求することもできるし
研究することもできるし
研究したり 調べたり 探したりするということは
この働きを延々とするということなんです
例えば体のこと私たちも知ってますけど
それ延々とそれを調べようとしないんですね
それを延々と調べようとしている人々は医学の世界なんですね
植物はみんな知ってるんだけど
延々とそれを追っかけていくことはしない
ですから それそうやる人々は植物学者であって
世の中のこと 人生のこと
我々も知ってますよ でもそればっかり考えても
そればっかりにふけてはいません
でも そればっかり考えて
それにふけっている方々は哲学者とか思考者だとか何とかと言うんですね
私たちは映画は見るんだけど
映画の評論家にはならないし
そんな感じで この何か追求していっちゃうと
そちらのプロになっちゃいますけど
それは基本的に誰にでも
どんな生命にもある働きなんです
犬連れて行ってみてください
散歩に 周りをきっちりと調べるんです
ミミズ たとえミミズにしたって目もないのに
鼻もないのに 生命だからちゃんと周りの環境を追求する
じゃあウイルスなんかは？同じこと
ちゃんとやってるんです
そういうのはどんな生命には基本的にあるもので
人間にはとことんいくらかできるんだから
違うものを作るだけのことです
この信心？え？信心 このえ？この
という 2つの働きがやると
物事は追求して理解することはできます
ですからありがたいものなんです
が まだ仏教 それでちょっとケチをつけてるんです
どういうことかというと
追求して追求してみると
それ言葉の世界 概念の世界になっちゃうんです
この追求するものはどうしても外の世界になっちゃうんです
自分がいて客体の世界のものを追求することになっちゃうし
それは知恵ではなくて直感ではないんだと
ですから 瞑想をすごく進めちゃうと
この人も死もカットするんです
何も言葉ない状態で体験だけする
そのものを そうするとありのままに体験できるんです
それには修行というものが必要なんです
実践という心育てる方法
今はできない ですから
今はものは外にあるものしか認識ができない
いわゆる客体を自分が主体で客体を知る
そうすると客体のある側面しか見えない
ですから 我々の知識はいつでも完全じゃない
どんな知識であろうが
同じことで 例えばある絵あって
有名な絵があって それは子供を見る
私が見る 専門家が見る
それ売買やってる人が見る
見方はそれぞれ違うんですね
頭の知識もそれぞれ違うんですね
ですからそのその人々は客体として絵を見ると
全然絵を見たことにはならないんです
その知識の世界はだから不完全なんです
ある側面で見ているんだと
瞑想の世界だけは経験完全なんです
あれは直観と呼ぶんですね
直接見る知ると その直観という言葉も
日本語の直感という意味じゃないんです
日本語で直感というのは
何の原因も分からなくて
ただそう思ってますよという意味なんですね
理由は分かりませんだけど
そんなもんだよと それは違うもので
仏教でいう直感というのは
文字通りにもう何も媒介しないで見ること
知ること だから直覚でもいいんです
ですから 心を育てる世界では
そういうふうな育て方がまたあるんですね
もう一つ 心にこのネガティブでもマイナスでもポジティブでもない
もう一つはこの喜びなんです
喜 喜び で 喜びという働きがあって
心はすごくそれ好きなんですね
ですから それはあんまりこのマイナスにもポジティブに入れなくても構いません
いわゆる人にはいいことをして喜ぶこともできるし
悪いことして喜ぶこともできるんですね
とにかく なんで人間がそんなに必死で生きてますかというと
なんか喜びたいんですね
何か楽しみたいんですね
それは心の希望なんですね
これは超面白くないんだからやってますよという人はいませんでしょ
そんな屁理屈なんです
本当はやりたくなくて
嫌で ものすごい面白くなくて
また難しくて だから私は一生懸命やってますよという人はいません
何かに凝り固まってやるならば
やっぱりその中から喜びを感じているんです
それも心の基本的な働きで
それを覚えておけば大変いいんです
そこら辺なんですね 脳内革命の本でも一応考えて書いているのは
心が喜びを感じたい それだったら感じてあげればいいんです
それからこのはごむ励むこと
精進という仏教用語ということがあります
それもネガティブでもポジティブでもないんです
それも結構気持ちいいものなんです
何かやりたい やりたくなることだけではなくて
ちょっと力入れて じゃあやろうではないかとというふうなこと
まだもう一つありますけど
それはただ聞くだけでいいんです
聞いて忘れてください
人間にはどんな生命でもやることに定着するっていうことあるんですね
あれ執着じゃないんです
何かやると それなんとなくこうってやらなくちゃいけないんですね
瞬間でも 分かりやすく言えば
この例えばたまに私のことなんですけど
誰かと何か本を読んだりとか
誰かが本を持ってきて
これはどんな言葉ですか？とか聞いちゃったら
なんとかそうですよと言える場合もありますけど
やっぱりそうは言えなくない
ちょっとちょっとこっちと自分でとって
これはこうですよと あの瞬間でそれに凍っちゃうんですね
そうでなきゃ ちゃんとしたことができなくなっちゃうんです
瞬間であろうとも ゲームやる時でも
あっち見てこちらでゲームできるわけじゃないんですね
やりたければきちんとそれを見て
それにやっぱり凍らないとダメなんですね
その何かに定着する やることに瞬間に
定着してからやってしまっちゃう
それから違うものに行くという
この それをあまりも大げさになっちゃったら
みんな凍りすぎて他のものを見えなくなったりして
もうたまにいるでしょ？例えば書き事に定着しちゃったら
もう家族にはもうどうなってもいいやとかね
もう もう離婚しようが
子供はもうどこに行くわ
不良になろうが関係なく
自分がもう書き事ばっかりやってるとか
そこでアルコールにもうそこをあまりにも定着しちゃったら
もう自分が死のうが関係ないとなぜならばそこら辺からネガティブポジティブ決められるんです
そちらでネガティブポジティブは決めません
凍ることはいいことに凍っちゃったらいいんです
例えば家族を幸福にしてやりますと
それに凍ってしまっちゃう
それはいいことであって
遊びに凍りますよと思っちゃったら
それは自己破壊のことになっちゃいますから
それは悪いことに凍ることであって
凍ること自体は悪くはないんです
喜びも同じ 喜びはいいことで
それで喧嘩して喜ぶではないかと思って
人を騙してお金取って
もうあの人を騙しちゃった
この人も騙しちゃったとか
成功しましたと 今日はもう何て言いますか
成果がありますよとか
喜びますけど 悪いことやってるんだから
それは良くない ですから
喜ぶならばいいことをして喜んでください
そういうふうなことを仏教で言っていて
だからそこら辺で一応その分野は終わりますが
今説明したのはネガティブとも言えない
ポジティブとも言えない
心の基本的な働き そういうのは我々はこれから何がネガティブか
何がポジティブかと勉強して
ポジティブの方にこういうものを育てればいいんです
じゃあこれからネガティブ思考なんですかと
まあもう時間はなくなりましたけど
すいません ネガティブ思考の場合も
どんなネガティブ思考にも基本的なネガティブ思考があるんです
基本 その基本っていうの一つは
この仏教ではこの何でしたっけ
痴と言うんですね 書くんですね
痴 山 山 平らにする 病気という
で こっちと言うんですね
それは智慧がないということなんですけど
あの それを基本的なんですね
この知っていうのは この我々の心っていうのは
物事を知られないようにできているんです
もう基本的なんです 例えば何か見たら
ああ これは白いでよ これ大きいと思っちゃうでしょ
本当はそんなこと見たことはないんです
これは長いですよ 短いですよと
そんな長い短いと目で見られるわけないんです
こんな小さな目で どうやってこんな小さな目で 100メートルぐらい長いものとかね
こんなすごい地球とか見えるはずがないでしょうに
目に入るのはほんのかすかな情報なんです
ですから 我々にこの目に入った情報と脳細胞が作った情報の差がわからないんです
私は見たんだからこれ大きいだよと堂々と言うだけなんです
私は見たんだから あの人は若いですよと
言うだけで でも本当は目に入る情報と
それは脳がどういうふうに解釈したかと
その区別はわからない
で あれは音楽だ これは音だとすぐ決めちゃうでしょ
でも耳に入るのは同じ音というエネルギーだけなんですね
そこで音というエネルギーは耳に入って
そのエネルギーは脳の中で
頭の中で いろんな音楽として
好きな音楽として 嫌いな音楽として
聞いて聞いて飽きちゃった音楽として
あるいは絶対二度と聞きたくない音楽として
あるいは雑音としていろんな解釈するんですね
嫌な人の声だと 私に悪口言ってるんだととか
いろんな解釈する でも耳に入るのはいつでも同じ音波だけなんです
その区別はわからないんですね
これ 誰のせいでもなんでもないんです
そうできてるんだから
それに知と言うんです
だから私は知はないよと
もう威張ることは誰にも不可能なんです
私はちゃんとした理性的な人間だよ
そんな嘘であって 生命であるならば
そのその生命にはもう認識過程はそういうふうに知られないように組み立てられているんです
真実は隠してるんです
そういうことを知と言うんです
ですから 我々のこの認識はほとんど正しいかないかわからない
自分勝手 花を見て人間が楽しみますけど
犬なんか見て全然楽しまないんですね
だから犬は犬の勝手で
そこで他の犬がおしっこでもかけてたならば
それを一生懸命嗅いでみるんですね
人間から見ればとんでもないやつですね
まあそんなきつい匂い嗅げなくてもいいのに
せっかく大事に育てる猫犬なのに
でも犬は犬にとってはそれは自分の世界であって
それによって喜びやら恐怖感やら色々感じちゃうんですね
弱いやつが先に歩いていたなと思ったら威張っちゃうし
先におしっこかけた犬が強いなと思っちゃったら
やっぱり気をつけていこう
気をつけて歩こうと尻尾を下ろして歩くという
それはもう犬の世界で
人間から見れば本当に行儀の悪い犬ですね
あっちこっちおしっこかけちゃって
臭くてしょうがないと
それは人間の勝手で ですから
私たちの知識っていうのは全然あてにならないんですね
このあてにならない知識に基づいて人間が行動する
そういうのはもうほとんど暗い考え方なんですね
例えば あの人は私のことを嫌いやと思うでしょ
その認識だから全然あてにならないでしょ
自分勝手に決めたんだから
無知だから 知だから それで嫌いだからと思った瞬間
心が暗くなっちゃって
それで嫌いな人に対する感情を作っちゃって
その感情で自分がもうむちゃくちゃなことをする
いわゆる鋭い刃物を持っていい加減振り回せるようなことなんです
そこで心も体も傷だらけで終わっちゃうんです
あるいは あの人 綺麗な人だなと思っちゃったら
そこで心の中でどんどんどんどんこの火がもう燃えちゃうでしょ
たまに病気にまでなっちゃうんですね
自殺までしちゃうんです
例えば 人が気になっちゃった
気に入った 気に入ったんだけど
なかなかその人は振り向いてくれない
で いろいろチャレンジするんだけど
向こうの興味は他の方にあるとか
それで自分がどんどん暗くなっちゃって自殺まですると
まあまあごく普通なんか新聞写真出てるんじゃないですか
その話なんか 有名な人もそういうことやっちゃいますから
そういうのはもう痴ですね
無知 もうだから結局自分がその人を見て気に入ったと
ああ かっこいい人だと思ったこと自体が間違いの認識なんです
見れるわけじゃないんです
ですから この暗い思考の基本は痴であると
ですから みんな同じ細菌でも汚染されてるんです
暗い思考の全ての生命が
明るい思考の人はいるわけじゃないんです
基本的だから これ あのもう次にもう一つ
二つがございまして それをまとめて言います
それはなんかね 大胆さみたいな意味なんですね
仏教の専門用語を言うと
もうちょっと話がもうあっちこっち広がってしまっちゃうんです
あんまりにも ですから
そこら辺ちょっと置いておいて
このなんか大胆なさみたいなものをここにあるんですね
いわゆるもうあまり考えずにやっちゃうんです
そこでこの仏教では この恥を知らない心と恐怖感を知らない心というふうな意味は使ってるんです
でもそこを説明の時間かかるんです
ですから 一応ちょっとしたこのなんか大胆さというふうなふうな理解で結構です
で そういうことで たまに我々はこのすぐ行動する
それから後で悩む すぐ喋っちゃう
喋ってから悩む それだったら先行動しなかった方がいいのに
喋らなかった方がいいのに
でもやってしまっちゃうんですね
何か行動する前にちょっと観察しようとしないんですね
やりたいんだからやってしまっちゃう
結果は気にしない その瞬間
そういうことがあって
まあ基本的にあっても
暗い思考の場合はそれは働きます
次の暗い思考の基本的なものはこれを覚えておいてください
落ち着きがないこと 落ち着きがない
仏教用語でこれ情動と言うんですが
それで意味が取れるかどうか分かりません
上すきです  まあ上すきでもいいんです
まあ大体 誰にでもありますね
なんとなく落ち着きがないんですね
いつでもそういう状態でいるんですね
そこから問題が生まれてくる
今日ですか？ 今日 こうだそうです
ここ上すぎですか  普通でいいんじゃないですか
そういう こと 基本的なことで
どんな暗い思考にもこういうものは入ってるんです
ですから この我々は瞬間でも心は浮つき状態だったら
あるいは落ち着きのない状態だったら
もう決まってるんです
もう暗いんだと そこにね
理解しやすいと思いますよ
いろんな人々に私はあなたはすごく暗く考えてるんではないかと怒られるんですね
冗談じゃないんだと 私はきちんと
ものすごくもう堂々と考えて活動しているんだと
ですから いつも私はもう損ばっかりしてるんですね
悪坊として口が悪いんだとかね
私は口が悪いんじゃなくて
まあ正直に喋ってるだけなんです
で ですから この自分がやっぱり落ち着きのない心だったら
必ず暗い方に行ってるんです
それわかるでしょ？ちょっとした
例えば料理している時でも落ち着いて気持ちよくやってるんですか？あーいけません
あーいけません こうやってるんですかと
それだったら 例えばまあ天ぷら揚げていると電話かけてきたと
それでいつもこれやったりして
あれがどうだってね 驚いたりとかね
落ち着いた人はやっぱり電話かけてあっても
今天ぷら揚げてる途中だから
もういいやと やめるか
取っておりませんと あるいは火を消して電話を受け取るかと
それで問題ないでしょ
そうすると万事何でも解決しちゃうんですね
そこで家が火事になったり
いろいろなって それもこの情炎なんですね
昨日も見たんだけど なんかどうかで火事ですか
この寝たきりの人が死んじゃったとかね
どこかでも落ち着きがなくなっちゃうと
すぐそこに火が出ちゃうんです
人生の中でも ですから
気をつけて明るくなりたいければ
一番早いのはこの知はちょっと置いておきましょう
それは瞑想でしかなくならないんです
瞑想しない限り 私たちの知識捨てられません
知識はもう九十九パーセント九パーセント嘘なんです
事実じゃないんです でもと言ったっても
そんな捨てられるわけないんだから
やっぱり知は置いておいたっても
情炎だけはね 落ち着きだけできますね
落ち着きましょうと 人間には一遍に一つしか仕事をできませんと
例えば赤ちゃんに哺乳瓶あげながら
じゃあ天ぷら揚げようとか両方できませんだから
赤ちゃんも殺しちゃって家も火事になっちゃうでしょうに
ちゃんと落ち着いて順番で考えて
赤ちゃん泣いてるんだったらもう哺乳瓶あげることは先であって
旦那さんがもう食べようと待っていたっても
それはしょうがないと
待っていてと みんなそういう落ち着いてる人は言うことを聞いてくれるんです
例えば子供たちなんかもう何かやれやれやれとお母さんもう責めちゃうでしょ
その点も落ち着いてる
お母さんがちゃんと言うんです
まあこれやってからやりますから
何のことないんです ですから
この情炎だけ捨てちゃって
きちんと落ち着いていただければ
心が明るくなってしまうんです
じゃあこれからごく普通なこの暗い思考っていうのは簡単で
まずむさぼり欲 欲っていうのは
ものは自分のためにしたがっちゃうんですね
自分のものにしたがっちゃうんです
そこであの前説明したこの高力ともあります
喜びもあります やりがいもあります
それに一貫性ですが 集中することもあります
それで気持ちはいいんです
物は自分もらっちゃうと
でも物が自分のものにしようとすると
いきなり暗くなっちゃうんです
なぜかと自分が満たしてないということで欲しがっちゃうんです
なくてはなりませんと
ですからもう欲があるとそこは暗いんです
欲張ってみてください
何かに すっごくきついんです
心の中で 暗くてもう 身動きはなくなっちゃうんです
で 僕はそれ子供を捕まえて試すことがあるんですね
で 元気で まあこうやって飛んで歩いていくところで
もう何のことなくおもちゃ屋さんとかいうところに連れて行っちゃうんです
で 窓から見えちゃうんだ
自分好きなものとかね
そこでいきなり足も手も全部ストップなんですね
で 目もまぶたも閉じないんですね
いきなりあの動きが完全にストップ状態
それを見て あんた何やってるんですか？って元にまた引っ張っちゃいますけど
たまにあまりもそこでたまらなくなっちゃったら
何のことなく泣くんですね
別になんだかんだ買ってもらえないということを知ってますけど
頭では でも自分にはコントロールできなく泣いちゃうんです
最近もなんか子供に電話かけてきて
なんか他の何か聞いた
聞かんと聞いたんだけど
泣いてるんです 僕 なんであんた泣いてるんですかと
そしたらいきなり思い浮かんだな
あれやと 本人も知ってたのに
買いたがっていたものはもう本当買えないんだと
全く知っていたのに やっぱり欲が生まれちゃったら
もうどうしようもない
暗くなっちゃうんです
子供見るとよくわかるんです
この欲っていうのはどれほど暗いものかと
大人は気がつかないだけで
で 奥さんいるのにもまた相手作ってみてください
人生は明るいか暗いかと
その光は暗くて暗くて身動きできないんですね
ですから 欲っていうのはもう暗い思考の基本で
で 物を欲しがる そこで危ないっていうのは
欲しがるっていうのは自分のものでない
外のもの 外のものというのは他人のものなんですね
それを奪おうとすると
向こう側は怒るんですね
商売の場合でも同じことなんです
どんなものにしたって
ものをもらおうとするっていうことは
商売して金儲けをすることでも
何だかんだも自分でないものを取ることだから
向こう側はいい気持ちにはなるわけじゃないんです
我々はお金を払って物を買っても
やっぱりタダでもらうのが一番面白いでしょうね
もう楽しいでしょうに
ですから 気持ちよくお金払ってるわけじゃないんです
お金払わなきゃくれませんだからお金払ってるだけなんです
だから買った品物にそれでちょっとしたものが当たったら
お客さんが文句言うこと恐ろしいでしょ
だから結局そこに暗い世界なんです
どうしようもないんです
だから できるだけ欲は完全に捨てるって言ったら
それは嘘の話になりますから
気をつけましょう 適当な欲でもう何て言いますか
満足しましょうと お釈迦様の教えはそういうこと
例えば結婚したならば
自分の奥さんで満足しなさいと
奥さんに子供が生まれたら自分の子供に満足しなさいと
隣の子はもっとかっこよくていいな
私もそんな風に育てたいとかね
そんなもの欲で ものすごい苦しみを感じちゃうんですね
障害の子供が生まれたって
もうそれで構いませんし
障害持ってる子供ならそれはしょうがないんだと
それで満足して一生懸命育てれば
そこに何もうものすごい喜びが生まれてくるんです
僕はある友達に言ったんです
この障害の子供を言うんって
ものすごく変わってるんですね
僕はあなた何言ってるんですか？と
大変いいんじゃないかと
とことん自分で面倒を見てあげなさいと
なぜかというと 他の子供たちはすぐ逃げちゃうでしょ
家から親と喧嘩するわ
戦うわ もう逃げちゃうわ
苦しみばっかりなんです
障害の子はもうものすごく愛情与えちゃうんですね
よく笑ってくれる 一緒にいてくれる
言う通りにしてくれる
だから本当に子育ての本当の充実感
幸福感は障害の子供が与えてくれるんです
なぜ赤ちゃんの時はすごい楽しいですかと
赤ちゃんも障害者障害者だからその時だけ可愛いんです
まあそんなことで欲は良くないということで
いわゆる欲は完全に捨てられませんから
いくらか合理的な欲で満足しようと
で 今日はこれ説明しようと思ったんだけど
時間なくなっちゃったし
このこの見解見解意見
あれ 何が暗いんですかね
いろいろ見解ありますね
人間には だから仏教を勉強するべきなんです
いまだに暗いと思わなかったものを
仏教で暗いと言っているものあるんです
仏教用語では見だけ書きますけどね
仏教用語としては あれ
暗いんです 別に見解を持ったってもいいでしょ
なんで暗いと思うんですか？でも暗いというのは
この見解と自我というものあるんですね
我々はアイデンティティを作るんですね
私ですと 例えば人がこう言うあなた
そういうふうな もう今レポート書いたんだけど
それは全部間違ってますよと言われたら
ものすごく暗くなっちゃって
ものすごく嫌になっちゃって
自分が攻撃されてぶっ壊されたと思っちゃうんですね
腹が立っちゃうんですね
なんであれただのレポートだから
自分が自分集めた情報で自分なりに考えて書いたものだから
別に間違ったってもどうったことないでしょ
あ 間違ってるんですかと
どこら辺間違ってるんですか？と聞けばいいでしょ
そうはいかないんです
あんた書いた文章はもうもうちょっと直した方がいいですよと言ったら
あ そう じゃあここどこら辺直した方がいいんですか？と聞けばいいんだけど
そううまくいかないんですね
腹が立つんです ものすごく自信がなくなっちゃうんです
ものすごいストレスが溜まっちゃうんです
だから見解は暗いんです
それなぜかというと 自分の意見は自分だと知だから無知だからそうすごく思っちゃうんです
まあわかりやすい例で言うならば
例えば自分を応援している人がいると
他の党を応援している人がいると
その二人が話し合いになっちゃうと喧嘩になっちゃうんですね
例えば友達だったら いくら自分とけなしても
友達けなしてるわけじゃないでしょ
友達が自分をけなしてると思っちゃうんですね
国会でもよく喧嘩ありますから
ただ 国会の事業だから別に個人のものじゃないんだから
もうきちんと喋り 話し合えばいいでしょ
そうはいかない ものすごい自我があって
俺という概念があってやってるんですね
ですから 完全に暗いんです
国会はものすごいいっぱい照明使ってますけど
それでも暗いんです 見学にいらっしゃったことあるでしょうね
すごい暗いところなんです
どんな国会でもね ものすごい豪華ことは確かです
自分の国は貧しいんだけど
国会に行ったらびっくりするんです
豪華さに でも僕はいつも言うのは暗いと
これ 入るところからもう怖いんです
なぜかというと みんな自分の我を出す
でも戦うところだから
ですから この見解を持つなと
仏教の言い方は 例えば日本のご飯は美味しいんですよと言って
私と喧嘩する必要ないんです
私は美味しくないよと言うかもしれません
外国人だから だからあなた何言ってるんですかとかね
そういう それは別に 私は例えば日本のご飯を美味しくないよと言ったっても
その言った人は貶してるわけじゃないんです
でもそうなっちゃうんですね
自分の意見を述べたら
だから皆様意見述べるのはすごい怖いでしょ
日本の社会ではよくあることだから
アメリカと違って自分の意見だから言わないで
もうズルズルズルズルと逃げちゃうでしょ
なんであれは堂々と言わないのは
喧嘩になるんだから よく知ってるんです
日本人が アメリカ人より
だから自分の意見は言わない
全然言わない ですから
このそこら辺 すごく私たちは知識的な話だから
よく理解してほしいんですね
見解できたら自分とアイデンティティ化になっちゃう
同一化になっちゃう だからすごい怖いんです
自我が作る 見は確実に自我が作る毒なんです
自我を作る それどうすればいいんですか
見解はただの見解で 例えば私は日本の米よりはインディカ米がおいしいと言ったならば
私はインディカ米食べて育てられたんだから
自分の経験を言ってるだけであって
私は世界中の米を食べ比べて
ある美味しさという科学的な基準があって
それに比べてみて データ的に統計的にインディカ米がおいしいと言ってるわけじゃないんです
単なる自分の意見からできた意見
経験からできた意見だけ
何のこともない 日本のご飯がおいしいということもまた同じく
日本の米を育てて食べて育てられた人々は
自分の経験に基づいて
日本の米はおいしいやというだけのことで
どんな米もおいしいわけでもなく
おいしくないわけでもないんです
事実は すべての意見は世の中にはそんなもんなんです
ある人の その人に見え見えた範囲で作ってる
結論 結論であって 決してその人ではありません
ですから 私のすべての知識
私の持っているありとあらゆる意見というのは
ただの知識と意見であって
私じゃないんです 一番この人間の怖い方はそこらなんです
怒るな 怖いよというのは大体誰でもわかってるよ
これはわかってないんです
なんで会社で会社に通ってそんなに疲れるんですかね？なんでそんなに病気になるんですかね
これ 意見のぶつかり合いなんです
なんで世界に戦争あるわ
色んな争いあるわ 今北朝鮮の人が亡命しているんだと
放っておけばいいのに
ものすごい問題でしょうに
大したこともないでしょうに
二人ぐらい国逃げたんだからって
国は倒せるわけでもないし
国の全部情報を持っていったって別にだからって何のこともないし
そうはうまくいかないんですね
すごい見解で私と思ってるんだから
そこで戦争まで行っちゃう
それでソ連のなんか人をまた殺されちゃって
暗殺されちゃって そこで国同士でも緊張状態で
危なくてしょうがないんですね
世界中そうでしょう いかにバカバカらしいかと
ただの見解 例えばソ連は共産主義でいた時は
アメリカとヨーロッパが片っ端からありとあらゆる武器を作って作って作って
地球は二〇回でも殺される
爆破されるぐらいものを作っちゃう
共産主義はただの見解だからもう放っておけばいいでしょう
それで共産主義の側も
もうアメリカはそういう勝手な考え方やってるんだと
ヨーロッパはヨーロッパで勝手な考えでいいんじゃないかと
放っておけばいいのに
我々はソ連の国民を幸せにすればいいんじゃないかと
そうじゃなくて もう世界中共産主義広げようではないかと
国家主義でやろうではないかと思って
もう結局自分たちみんなもうダメになってしまっちゃうんです
バカバカしいんです ですから
見解っていうのは大変な個体思考なんです
だから なんでみんな夫婦喧嘩するんですか？見解なんです
自分言ったことに旦那さんが反対しちゃったら
なんか自分負けましたと思っちゃうんですね
なんであなたはとまた喧嘩になっちゃうんです
ただ意見の交わせだからもういいんじゃないんですか
それに ですから これあるんだから
人間に知識的な対話さえできない
だから仏教から言うならば
一般の方々がやってる対話なんかディスカッションとか何にもならない
もう無駄なんですね 時間の
全然会話にもならない
ディスカッションにもならない
ただのもう見解のぶつかり合い
ぶつかり合い ですから
ちょっとだけでもこの仏教の世界を理解すると
本物の知識人が生まれてくる
平和っていうのはすぐ生まれてくるんです
心の問題ですから じゃあまあ
暗い思考で終わっちゃったんだけど
時間が また暗い思考 またいくつかあります
暗く終わってしまっちゃいます
で 私はこの見解の方が一応今日は言いたかったところなんです
なぜならば なんとなく面白いことを言わなきゃ自分が気が済まないんだから
皆様も本当にそうかなと疑うところですからね
意見というのはありがたいでしょうと思ってるんだから
本当は意見というのはありがたくないんだけど
どうせ意見しか出せない人間には
意見は側面である 完全な面
全面ではないんです 自分が見た範囲の意見なんです
それは自分ではありません
だから違う角度で見せたら人は意見変えるでしょ
だから我々はうすーっと毎日意見変えてるんです
例えば皆様方 今日勉強して
今までに仏教に対する意見はいくらか変えるんです
それは変えさせないられないんです
ですから すぐ変えられるもんだから
それになんで喧嘩するんですかね
それになんで戦争するんですかね？夫婦喧嘩やら兄弟喧嘩やら
喧嘩喧嘩喧嘩ばっかりして
せっかくの幸福も消えちゃう
なんで人は意見持って
それと自分だと同一化してひどい目に遭いますかというと
それ面白いんですね これ私に意見だよと
ある気があるんですね
喜びが 私がもう決めたんだよと
私の見解だよと そこでやられちゃうんですね
ですから このくだらない見解を持って喜びを感じるよりは
もうただの見解だと すぐ新しい情報入っちゃったら
すぐそれ変えればいいんです
それにやってることです
みんな 見解は変えて変えていく
でも同一化することはずっとやっている
例えば戦争の時はある意見があって
それにみんな命かけていて
戦争終了したところで違う意見を作って
それにまた命かけていて
新しい意見にすぐ同一化しちゃう
これは私ですよと この意見間違ってるのが分かったら
この意見が私ですよと
すぐ私が変えちゃうんです
ですから この見解はとても暗い思考だと覚えておいてください
意見っていうのは でも意見持つなということじゃない
意見伸びるなということじゃない
本当に落ち着いて どいつかしないで
正しく意見の伸び方をお釈迦様は明るい方でおっしゃっているんです
まず客観的に観察する
状況判断する 客観的に
それから自分の意見は伸びた方がいいか
伸ばない方がいいかとちゃんと見る
見てから伸びる時も これは私どもの意見ですが
私の考え方ですがと言うんです
いわゆる条件付けて 私はこれはこうではなくて
こうなった方がもっといいなと思いますよと
と言うんです 私の研究結果から言えば
これはこうではなくてこうですよと
でも人はそうじゃなくて
これはこうじゃなくてこうですよ
と言っちゃうでしょ それで危ないんです
日本の宗教の本はだいたい新興宗教の本なんか
これはこれだという感じで書いてあるんだから
ですから簡単に捨てられちゃう
だから嘘だと 私が思うには
私は感じる通りはと書けば自分を出してないんです
だから仏教ではいつでもしゃべる場合はそういうふうに条件を付けろ
いわゆる絶対的な Absolute statement
絶対的な表現するなと
絶対的な表現ないんです
だから日本人はアメリカからイエスノーをはっきりしなさいと言ってますけど
あるわけないんです 本当は
イエスノーは はっきりしたイエスノーは
ですから この仏教での Absolute statement という
この絶対的というかね
まあ無条件な言葉っていうのは言うなと
全て条件付けて で そういうふうにお話すると
すごく自分の頭が冴えてきて
明るくなってしまっちゃうんです
そうすると元気で自分の意見を述べるんです
自分の意見は壊されだっても
まあ私はそう思っただけですよと言っちゃえば終わるんです
いい 私は読んだ本ではこういうこういうこういうふうにありましたから
こういう結論出ましただけですよと
だから私に当たるなとか
そういうふうな立場だったら
どんな意見でも言えるんです
あるいは人にあなたバカですよと言いたくないでしょ
言うのは危ない こういう立場で言えるんです
何のこともなく なぜならば
私はあなたの行動をいろいろ観察したところで
そのそういうところから言うならば
あんたは本当にバカですねと
何のこともなく言えるんです
だからその人をバカになる必要もないし
怒る必要もないし その人はそれをちゃんと見ているならば
あなたが見ているところは違うんですよと
見てないところいっぱいあります
そうですか それだったらそれも教えてちょうだいということで終っちゃうんです
喧嘩にはならない どんな意見でも述べられる
意見述べなと仏教で言わない
見解持つなと ということで
じゃあ次にやる暗い思考っていうのは嫉妬
怒り うん それから物惜しみと言うんですかね
それから後悔 後悔する
悪いことしちゃったなとかね
失敗しましたなとか後悔するでしょ
よく 例えば子供なんかちょっとした
まあやっぱり年は変わる瞬間でも
どんな子供でもものすごいとんでもないことをやっちゃいますから
私の育ち方悪かったなとか後悔しちゃうんですね
あれで悪い暗くなっちゃうんです
育ち方悪かったとか 何考えてる？自分にできるだけのことをやったんだから
それでいいじゃないんですか
悪くたっても あるお母さんが自分の娘さんが高いお金要求してるんだと
大学生でエステに行きたいんだと
言ったらなんかこの私に聞くんです
本当にそんなお金出した方がいいんですか？ないかと
ものすごい怒ってもうお金出せと言ってるんだと
僕はなんでエステに行きたがってるんですか？と
食べ過ぎて食べ過ぎ太ってるんだと
そしたら僕はすごい静かにそんなことだったらもういくらエステに行ったって世界を戦国歩いたってももうダメですよ
そう言われたってもうわかってはいるんだけど
自分もやっぱりもう私は今まで厳しく育てたんだから
自分が食べ過ぎになったんだと
一切たまっちゃったんだ
母の育ち方が悪いんだから
ですからエステに行くお金出せと
バカバカらしい言い方でしょ
自分がストレス溜まっちゃって食べ過ぎになっちゃったならば
それやめればいいでしょう
エステに行ってただ体ちょっとぶん殴ってもらっても
蒸し器で蒸してもらっちゃっても痩せるわけないでしょうに
それ終わったらまた食べるでしょ
そこで母が悩んで 私はやっぱり育ち方悪かったね
あまりに厳しすぎるとかね
僕はそれに怒ったんでいい加減にしろと
あなたは自分できるだけのことやったんだから
それでいいじゃないかと
かえって子供に怒られると 1円もあげるなと
それよりは病気に病院に連れて行けと精神科に
精神科に連れて行ったらいいんだと
病気だとなんて あなたの育ち方は悪くないんですよ
なぜならば お母さんというのは完全じゃないんだから
天才じゃないんだから
自分にできるだけのことを子供にやってあげる
それを後で計算すると
良かろうか悪かろうが
それはしょうがないんです
だから仏教では後悔だけはするなと
後悔っていうのはもう暗い
物惜しみ また同じ暗い
自分のものは人にあげたくなくて
きつく家の鍵かけたくなったりとかね
暗いでしょ その場合は
みんなおいでおいでとかね
一緒にご飯食べようと
もし奥さんが怒るならば人を連れてくるんだけど
あんたもういい加減にしなさいと
私にはそんな料理できないとかそう言われるお母さんが確実に暗いんです
それで家も不幸なんですね
なぜならば旦那さんが友達がいるんだけど
呼べないんだから 自分の家に
全部暗くなっちゃうんですね
もし奥さんに料理作るのが体が弱くて大変だったら
何のことないでしょうに
あなたもこっちいらっしゃい
じゃあこれ作りなさい
これ作りな 言えばいいでしょうに
旦那に 旦那がちゃんとやってあげるんで
その場合は そうするとみんな仲良く料理作ってお客さんに接待するんだから
すごく明るく元気で 旦那さんにしても自分が作った料理だからお客さんに堂々と出せちゃうし
そこで旦那さんが料理作るのお前の仕事ではないかと
それ暗いんです それも暗いんです
料理は誰が作ってもいいでしょ
自分みんな食べてるんだから
誰が決めたんですかね
料理はお子さん作るものであると
そうじゃなくてお願いすれば
私はもう疲れてるんだから
あなたにお願いしますよと
あなたはこれやってちょうだい
私はこれやっておきますと
そういう契約でやればいいのに
だからそこら辺も明るい方で
みんなやっぱり残念ながらまあ暗い暗い方でやってます
じゃあ時間になりましたから
残ったものありますか？もうちょっと
あのもうもうこれはどうしても言わなくちゃいけない
睡眠 昏沈睡眠ですね あの昏沈睡眠って二つあるんですね
昏沈というのはあんまり活動したくなくなる鈍い状態
心も体もなんかまあどこかでどこかに座ってホッとしたいとかね
そういう気持ちが出てくると
暗いとすぐ気をつけてください
何かやりたくなるのは明るいんです
睡眠はまあ睡眠でいつでも寝るとかね
寝たくて寝たくてとかね
眠たくてしょうがないとかね
それはもう確実に暗い
まあそういう今言ってることは僕には絶対的なことで言えるんでいらっしゃらない
それは法則だからね しょうがないんです
それで私の意見を述べてるわけじゃなくて
釈尊の悟りの教えを言ってるんです
ですから もし文句あるならば
お釈迦様にどうぞぶん殴ってぶつけてください
私は放っておいてください
で 睡眠はもう暗いんです
疲れて寝ることではなくて
睡眠なんです ここをやったりしてね
で 眠れない眠れないと悩んだりしてる
眠れなかったら何か仕事でもしてください
夜でも眠れないんだったら
僕でもほとんど 1時間 2時間が寝ないんで
夜は面白くて面白くてみんな寝てるんだから
何も何も悪い波動はないし
外はうるさくはないし
ですごい面白くなっちゃうんです
それで 3時になろうか
3時半になろうがも 4時になろうが全然気が付かないんです
ただ起きていろいろくだらないことをやったりしてるんです
大したことはやってないんだけど
で それも他の人のこと
あんた病気ではないかと言うかもしれませんだけど
もうまあ 1時間半ぐらいは寝ますけどね
まあ寝るより僕は体止まってもらうんですね
体の機能を 頭はなかなか寝ないんだけどね
ですからこの まあそれで別に病気じゃないんだから大丈夫ですけどね
そこであのある薬がもらって
それ飲んだらまあまあちょっと眠くもなりますよとあったんです
で よく眠れるんだと 僕はすぐそう言ったのは私にはそういう効果は要りませんと
でも私は他のことに体の調子が悪くてね
それを直せると言ってるんだから
飲んでみますということで飲んでみたんだけど
全然眠くならない でも他の効果はしてくれるんです
体には 他のいい効果はしててしてくれるんだけど
熟睡できるということだけはしてくれないんです
だから試しにもっと大量に飲んでみようという馬鹿なこともしない
まあとにかく睡眠というのは暗い思考と思ってください
まあそこら辺でだいたい暗い思考っていうのは終わるんです
まあ最後にあるのはもう何でも疑うと
疑うっていうのはいい気持ちの疑いじゃなくて
もう自分で理解しようというエネルギーないんですね
まあどこかの嘘やろ そんなものは
とかね どこかの誰かのデタラメでしょうとかね
私はもうそんなことやりませんよとか
なんかすごい汚い疑いなんですね
それから不安も出てくるしね
本当にそれで大丈夫ですか？本当にそれで大丈夫ですか？とか
例えばある医者のところに行くと
本当にあの医者は大丈夫ですか？とかね
疑いでいくと そうじゃそれだったら行かないか
行って楽しそうではないかというどっちかなんですね
あの占い師は本当に正しく当たるかないかとかね
半信半疑で行く必要ないんです
半信半疑で行かない お金払わないと
行くならば じゃあ試してみよう
あの人本当に当たるかないかと
という明るいことでやってみればいいんです
それで占ってもらったところ
全部嘘だ 全部嘘やね あの人はあまり当たらないやと明るく帰ればいいのに
ですから 人に騙された騙されたとよく文句言われる人がいるんですね
あれは疑なんです 最初から
最初からも半信半疑であったし
しっかりその人言ったことも聞いてないし
後で自分が騙されたと
自分のせいなんですね
本当にその人言ってることは正しいかわからない
正しいかないかわからない場合は
まあしょうがない とりあえず試してみると
試すんだから 後で騙された結果になったっても気持ちはいいんですね
やっぱりあの人はインチキでしたと
ですから 疑も暗いんです
疑っていうのは書いてない
疑いな疑いです それも暗いんです
大体仏教で厳密に言うと
暗い色はそれぐらい それ以上なし
じゃあ そこら辺で話を終了します
どうもありがとうございます